[Music]
the first people to spot the russian
invasion of ukraine
were actually on the other side of the
globe
before putin had ever said anything
about his assault a group of academics
in california
noticed an unusual buildup of traffic at
the border and concluded correctly that
the invasion had begun
how did they do it
using satellite technology
six months ago i left active duty with
the marine corps and joined a defense
technology startup in washington dc
i was surprised when they asked me
to help build a military space strategy
i didn't know anything about space
i could barely tell you the difference
between star wars and star trek
i did want to be an astronaut as a kid
but if you're afraid of roller coasters
you're probably scared of rocket ships
too
i did learn that summer that for the u.s
space is considered the ultimate high
ground and as a result we've already
militarized it quite a bit
above us right now there are enough
satellites to take a picture of every
square meter of the planet
multiple times a day
in 2023
the us is planning to field a
space-based laser
that's next year
but guess who else is militarizing space
russia
and china
as a marine officer i can tell you
we're in a dead sprint
and no one is settling for a second
but here's what concerns me
using space to find better ways to kill
each other
is easy
what's harder
is using space constructively
to lift all boats
and not just deep in great power
competition
space is supposed to be the final
frontier
so is militarizing the hell out of it
the best that we can do
maybe there's a better way
this past quarter i took a class called
climate ventures
where i teamed up with aeronautics and
astronautics students
to explore ways that space technology
can solve climate change
during our research i found this really
interesting company called ghg sat
they're using satellite-based radar
technology to visually identify
methane emissions across the planet the
first time we've ever been able to do
that
another company
another approach
sponsored by harvard university and
backed by bill gates
uses a different approach
they use space technology
to spray fine particles into the upper
atmosphere and scatter sunlight and
actually cause global cooling
that would be a game changer for global
warming
but climate change is just an example
i think that space technology has the
ability to solve many problems in many
industries
for the benefit of all of us
and it would be great
if commercial space was on par with
military space
but there's two problems with that
first
though space is technically infinite
we're actually running out of it really
fast
between 90 to 600 miles above the planet
is a sweet spot where 90
of satellites have been deployed
we call this low earth orbit
or leo
90 to 600 miles sounds like a lot
but in leo
satellites don't sit still
they actually move and orbit
so instead of picturing a dot that
surrounds the planet
you should actually picture
a ring that goes around it instead
in 2021 the un estimated that there were
7
500 satellites in leo
that's a lot of rings
it creates a real traffic jam or in this
case a space jam
what makes it more complicated
is that when satellites collide with
each other
or when they reach the end of their
useful life they actually get stuck
because we don't yet know how to remove
space debris
so
when broken satellites and debris are in
space and leo they create a higher
likelihood
for more accidents which creates
more debris
and it's a vicious cycle
it's hard to tell how much space is left
in leo
but we're definitely running out
this leads to the second problem
because space technology is so expensive
defense has an outsized voice
in how commercial space dollars are
being spent
sure
spacex is a hundred billion dollar
company
but when the government is spending 54
billion dollars on space per year
it's hard to ignore them in your
business case
military organizations like space force
and the national reconnaissance office
are also outsourcing their space
technology to the commercial sector
so even though it looks like
a lot of money is flowing into the
commercial sector into commercial space
it's often just a trojan horse for more
military spending
personally
i completely understand why the u.s is
rushing to military space and if i'm
being honest i understand why russia and
china are doing the same
but great power competition doesn't
benefit humanity
what benefits humanity in space
is combating climate change or frankly
any use of commercial space
so i'm here to sound the alarm
the world's militaries are filling space
up fast
and the opportunity to shift the
trajectory of the space industry is
shrinking
so what now
if you're someone who's relationship
with space is primarily just watching
guardians of the galaxy
you still have a very important role to
play
we need to demonstrate
both an awareness of
and a demand for
commercial uses of space technology
and not just for climate change
but also for agriculture
finance
urban studies
maritime activity
and even politics
space technology has come so far
but unless you're in the military
you probably don't know about it
but now that you all do
you can help amplify the demand
for commercial space technology
start
by exploring the imagery that's been
collected by satellite companies
any stanford student has access to the
historical database of planet one of the
largest space companies with nearly 500
satellites in low earth orbit in leo
and data going back to 1972
i challenge you all
to use this data
and show us
something constructive that you can
build with space technology
planet's historical database is
available to mit and asu students as
well
but i urge planet and all satellite
imagery companies to make their data
available to everyone an open source
imagine the scientific doors that we
could collectively unlock
by demonstrating a ground swell
of demand
and finding novel ways to use space
technology that no one has ever seen
before
you
can help ensure that the future
direction of the space industry is
equally influenced by commercial needs
as well as military needs and avoid
the over-militarization of space
i'll leave you with one last story
two days ago russia
severed the internet in ukraine
a classic military move to disable your
opponent's command and control
it looked like a crippling blow
but within 24 hours elon musk announced
that starlink a satellite-based internet
service provider
would now be online in the ukraine for
the first time
picture that
space
not just an extension of our earthly
conflicts
but instead a solution for them a way to
resolve what we're doing to each other
here
that
is the power of space thank you
[Music]